I don't know if it's by popular demand
he brings in a theme song and his tail
between his legs
Shayne Irving we have to recap last
week's picks unfortunately we have to
yes you do that's how it works we praise
you we bury you tall so you covered
Mississippi State you won that one out
right did not cover with Wyoming
Michigan Missouri SMU Wow hold on now
let's talk about SMU for a second miss
PHP in the first quarter lose the cover
by half a point still along shaving is
what is point-shaving that should be an
investigation by the NCAA that's what
that is northern Illinois in Lincoln
view by one out yeah you did 14 not
didn't and then we went to the NFL
Vikings did not cover that will hold on
now I got the news of Sam Bradford
wasn't starting on Sunday morning bought
Pitt minus nine and a half it's up on
Twitter you can check that so I lost ten
cents on that one okay the Jews lost the
juice Giants did not cover
well that was at that game many but they
still didn't cover Eagles did not cover
either
all right let's also recap the other bet
you lost worst half eighteen and a half
points Paulie and Seton took army
against Ohio State with 18 and a half
points
Ohio State goes up 14 nothing in the
first quarter the first quarter and all
of a sudden I'm thinking this is not
gonna be pretty
and then all of a sudden army scores was
like a 99 yard drive here 10 minutes and
it's 14-7 and it's playing out exactly
as Paulie said they're gonna run the
clock if they get a touchdown and then
they have a chance to keep Ohio State
off the field so you lost $100 to the
front only one other time as a service
academy drove the ball 99 yards a
high-stake maybe did it a few years ago
this was clearly collusion on the part
of Urban Meyer with him in his khaki
pants trying to support America and let
that service academy cover his
counterpart over in Michigan in the same
damn thing and let that service academy
cover both wear khakis both from the
Midwest both in the big 10 you can't
tell me there's not a connection Danny
they're Patriots yeah their hatred just
boiling
that's what we were banking on the
patriotism of Urban Meyer and Jim
Harbaugh Harbaugh loves America more
than football
okay you have the money you've got $100
yeah I got the money I got the money
these guys would like to double up and
let it roll is that right
front row do you have a game for che and
he has to be willing to accept it right
we have two games che
two games you ready yeah I'm ready
Perdue is getting ten versus Michigan
seven in the first half talk to me would
you like to pitch on now Paulie I got a
cheese dog ready for me to eat chirping
on the internet all damn weekend you can
surf right now let's go okay Perdue with
the first half covering getting seven
points will take Perdue next option come
on hear me out
do you want it I want to hear your next
option Paulie we're gonna say get a
2-game we're actually gonna take two
bets we want you to take ball four
unbelievable first off with the entire
concept of this is stupid you present me
with a bet and then I either have to
take it or don't I need what if I
present you with a bet you're the
professional we're the amateur not a
professional I have a serious gambling
problem and you're all enabling me let's
be clear we also like West Virginia big
they're given 21 to Kansas Seaton's West
Virginia Mountaineers given 21 Kansas
Bob so you want the full game there huh
you want West Virginia - 21 yes or you
want Perdue plus seven in the first half
or both can you put 50 on each game a
surf-and-turf big boy
so full game Kansas plus 21 or halftime
and you got Michigan kitchens except lay
in the seventh and not a bowl
no I don't want Michigan I want that
patriotic son of a gun out of my life
forever 21 cam taking Jayhawks plus 21
you know what the other pack so far :
you got me up against a wall here Paulie
it ain't right take a ball make the pole
don't you tell me what to do we'll
double the ratings on these games I do
like khakis - cept in the first half so
that's probably a losers
give me both give me both let's go this
is why you got a gambling problem yeah
Dan right there right there I know he
had a couple of beers already this
morning all right well if you could get
anything in here besides three week old
how old is that beer I was drinking I
don't know when Paulie bought that Bush
light
oh that's at least 14 months old and
warm day that warm as hell all right
give me your picks for this week now
here we go
rattles slow down
I got New Mexico the Lobos plus 11 and a
half
Michigan State plus three and a half
Colorado plus 11 Iowa plus 12 and a half
at home night game at Kinnick
that's a double banger Dani South
Alabama - three and a half that's five
at Cinco we're good you got anything I
don't want to talk about the NFL right
now Danny if you start I don't want it
going it into it we start talking about
the Ivy League gender I'm not what if
the Cowboys lose to the Cardinals holy
Enoch custom holy moly that's what I do
here you can't get me home okay holy
moly
if the Cowboys lose the car go for what
Danny well I'm just curious soon just at
the end of the world - it's already the
end of the world I have the big
everybody thinks I'm stupid or that I
don't understand football when I talk
about running damn ball my point is to
play To Your Strengths
if the Cowboys lost to the Broncos on
the road by running the ball 30 times I
would not be that upset you cannot drop
the team it depends how they lose is my
pony fanny okay how they lose let's say
they lose by Zeke's rushing 31 times
what's the score they lose 2824 how'd
they lose it Zeke got the ball thirties
out there special teams hurt him and
Arizona had a couple of big plays
I'd be upset but not as I said I am
right now all right so your NFL picks
you'll walk you'll keep them to yourself
those are on the Twitter let me well
okay well so we can you can access those
on the Twitter Shaner
actually we've got two pics with the
front row they're on the way we're gonna
let that ride and she went to the Giants
game yeah big mistake that was on Plus
with 48 other Giants fans left some
commuter lot in Connecticut and it took
us to New Jersey to watch the New York
Giants and the Twitter Club yeah it was
stupid
and then well the Dallas Cowboys gonna
playing down yeah it's a big upset amah
I have I'm very upset about that Danny
it's stupid all the stadiums should be
in the city that they claim and be in a
part of the neighborhood that's how it
worked I had to go to MIT Life Stadium
and what feel I fall down as many times
he could which was hilarious except I
had money on sling blade that didn't
help my disposition at all you took the
Giants
I didn't think you would ever bet on
Slingblade at home against the Lions it
made a little more sense when I made the
better obviously watching the game I
decided I made a horrible mistake and so
I continued drinking as much beer as
possible well I'll let you do that I'll
let you get back to that so those are
where is it by the way the beer we had a
discussion about this I would get a beer
and a shot after my piss Paulie can you
see if we gonna do I have to sign
something up now are you walking back to
work yeah yeah yeah Danny I'm gonna take
him in my steps yeah
how about I get an uber I get you a beer
in a shot here we go the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience